hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español cada 2 de noviembre
se conmemora el día internacional para
poner fin a la impunidad de crímenes
contra periodistas hablamos una fecha
clave por supuesto para todos los
comunicadores a lo largo de todo el
mundo y es por eso que nos acompaña
guillelme de canela eres jefe de la
sección de libertad de expresión y
seguridad de periodistas de la unesco
hablamos por supuesto de la organización
de las naciones unidas para la educación
la ciencia y la cultura señor canela
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24 quisiera preguntarle en primer
lugar cuál es hoy en día el estado de
situación en términos de crímenes contra
periodistas por un lado preguntarle si
maneja frisa cifras perdón y también en
términos de regiones qué países son los
más afectados
un placer hablar con usted y con la
gente que sigue france24
sí o sea el estado sigue siendo complejo
en todo el mundo justamente por la fecha
del 2 de noviembre estamos divulgando
nuevas cifras que vienen que hacen parte
del informe que se publica cada dos años
por la directora general de la unesco
sobre el tema de los asesinatos de
periodistas y la cuestión de la
impunidad por estas cifras de américa
latina en este año 2018 2019 que son los
datos que estamos publicando en este por
la conmemoración del 2 de noviembre es
la región más violenta contra
periodistas y desafortunadamente el otro
problema que es el problema de la
impunidad sigue estando muy alto de cada
10 crímenes contra periodistas 9 siguen
impunes aunque la del dato ha mejorado
un poquitito en relación al último
informe el último informe no teníamos
10% de crímenes resueltos en el informe
actual este número subió para
13 por ciento esperamos que eso se
configure en una tendencia en los
próximos años pero sin embargo sigue
siendo siguen siendo datos muy graves
desde el punto de vista de la lucha
contra la impunidad ahora ustedes de la
situación en la región américa latina no
que es bastante preocupante como decía
méxico dentro de la región es uno de los
países más afectados por este flagelo
verdad como es la situación en este país
si es desafortunadamente en relación a
de los asesinatos es el país de la
región con el mayor número de asesinatos
sin embargo es importante también poner
atención que los crímenes contra los y
las periodistas en el mundo no se
resumen a los asesinatos que es la forma
más grave también estamos notando un
conjunto una ampliación de violaciones
contra la seguridad de los y las
periodistas en distintas y en distintos
formatos por ejemplo aunque desde el
punto de vista de los asesinatos
felizmente las mujeres periodistas sean
muy mucho menos afectadas que los
hombres en relación por ejemplo a la
violencia en línea al acoso digital
las mujeres periodistas están sufriendo
enormemente en una escalada creciente
por eso por ejemplo la unesco está
realizando una encuesta global sobre el
tema del acoso en línea contra mujeres
periodistas y recientemente hemos
divulgado datos por ejemplo sobre los
los ataques a periodistas
y protestas sociales y fíjense ustedes
hemos identificado violaciones de la
seguridad de los y las periodistas que
cubren protestas en 65 países a lo largo
de los últimos 5 años entonces realmente
tenemos en distintas frentes del
asesinato clara es la cosa más cruda
pero en otras frentes un datos
alarmantes sobre la cuestión de la
seguridad de los de los de los
profesionales de la comunicación en todo
el mundo ahora preguntaron que surge
para todos es quién o quiénes son los
principales victimarios quienes están
detrás de estos crímenes de estas
violaciones a los derechos humanos
si la del fenómeno se vuelve cada vez
más complejo complejo de relación
que son los victimarios cómo comer su
pregunta entonces tenemos crimen
organizado tenemos políticos locales
tenemos fuerzas de seguridad tenemos
dentro del crimen organizado distintos
tienen de tipos de bandas criminales
pero también es interesante notar las
temáticas que esos periodistas estaban
cubriendo mientras sufren estos dos
tipos distintos tipos de violencia
mientras que en un pasado no tan lejano
el mayor número de periodistas
asesinados eran periodistas que estaban
en áreas en países donde había o hay
conflictos armados abiertos hoy eso se
ha invertido en proporciones
significativas y la mayor parte de los
periodistas estacionados están en países
donde no hay conflictos armados abiertos
y los temas que están cubriendo
aunque la gente a veces piensa que eso
que los periodistas están cubriendo
guerras y ese hacer lo que imparte es
verdad o grandes casos de corrupción que
también es verdad pero no encontramos
periodistas cubriendo violaciones de
derechos humanos cubriendo crímenes
medioambientales cubriendo criminalidad
organizada en general entonces realmente
cubriendo por ejemplo elecciones o
cubriendo protestas entonces el abanico
de temas cotidianos que afectan la vida
de cada uno de nosotros que estos
periodistas estaban desnudando que estos
periodistas estaban buscando la verdad y
que eso fue parado fue portado en
función de distintas formas de violencia
es enorme y por eso la unesco está
fortaleciendo esta campaña que tenemos
que proteger el periodismo es proteger
la búsqueda por la verdad ahora pongamos
toda esta tarea periodística no en este
contexto tan particular que estamos
viendo en este año 2020 por supuesto
vinculado a la pandemia de coronavirus
kobe 19 desde una escuela en de una de 5
de miass generada
por la pandemia no y por las noticias
falsas falsas perdón cuéntenos qué es
esta de sinfonía y por qué era una
escuela considera también como otra
pandemia
si él ya venía creciendo desde los
últimos años afectando procesos
electorales del fenómeno de la
desinformación sin embargo con la
pandemia del cob y 19
hemos detectado un crecimiento absurdo
de la cantidad y de los formatos de
desinformación en relación al caso
específico de la pandemia pero también
sobre otras situaciones entonces la
unesco publicó como has mencionado dos
textos importantes para analizar este
fenómeno y ahí llama esta situación
desde infamia y claro en la es
irónicamente en el momento que el
periodismo quizás sea más necesario
comparado a los últimos años porque el
periodismo es una forma de combatir este
fenómeno de la desinformación al mismo
tiempo está sufriendo lo que nosotros
estamos llamando de una tempestad
perfecta
no sólo el la cuestión de la violencia
física psicológica online como como
apenas habíamos estábamos hablando pero
también están sufriendo problemas
laborales graves o sea el número de
despidos de periodistas ha aumentado en
todo el mundo un problema serio de
viabilidad económica de los medios
periodísticos que afecta esta situación
y un problema regulatorio porque muchas
de estas leyes de emergencia que fueron
aprobadas supuestamente para para
resolver temas relacionados a pandemia
han disminuido la libertad de expresión
y el acceso de información pública sin
las justificativas que son aceptadas por
los estándares internacionales de
derechos humanos entonces tenemos una
ola de desinformación y al mismo tiempo
tenemos un periodismo que sería
fundamental para combatir esta ola que
es fundamental para combatir esta ola de
desinformación pero enfrentando una
tempestad perfecta de problemas
relacionados a la propia existencia y el
ejercicio del
les propongo hablar ahora de la libertad
de expresión un tema sobre el cual se ha
vuelto a abrir nuevamente el debate no
por estos días recientemente de resurgió
muchísimo es muy fuerte en la agenda
mundial a raíz de los ataques
terroristas en país con un docente que
fue decapitado por haber mostrado una
caricatura del profeta mahoma a sus
alumnos esto tuvo muchísimas
repercusiones a nivel internacional
geopolítico y quisiera preguntar a usted
señor guillermo tiene el límite es la
libertad de expresión
sí o sea la libertad de expresión es una
construcción muy interesante apasionante
para aquellos que se profundizan en eso
que tiene por lo menos más de 2000 años
de estudios sobre lo que significa este
derecho tan humano de comunicarnos
y en la versión más reciente de todo
este de este largo recorrido es la
declaración universal de los derechos
humanos en su artículo 19 y en los
textos que reglamentan este derecho que
es conocido como el pacto internacional
de derechos civiles y políticos este
pacto fue ratificado por casi todos los
países en sus artículos 19 y 20
establece cuáles serían las limitaciones
a la libertad de expresión por ejemplo
la más concreta de ellas es el llamado
discurso del odio que lleva a una
violencia concreta ahora las cortes
internacionales han establecido lo que
se llama de 13
de tres partes para tomar la decisión si
un determinado discurso debe ser
restringido o no y este test tiene que
analizar la legalidad o sea si es lo que
estás proponiendo esta aprobado en una
ley democrática la legitimidad pero
también la proporcionalidad de esta
medida en líneas generales aunque la
libertad de expresión no sea un derecho
absoluto y por lo tanto en casos muy
excepcionales y podría estar restricta
en todas las investigaciones a lo largo
de estos últimos años demuestran que la
mejor medida para resolver eventuales
problemas relacionados a la libertad de
expresión no es con menos libertad de
expresión pero sí con más o sea su
medida es donde encontramos a través de
la propia libertad de expresión contra
discursos a situaciones que sean
complejas como es el caso de la tesis de
la desinformación que usted me
preguntaba antes o por ejemplo con el
caso con algunos casos del discurso del
odio y en este sentido es muy importante
un otro una otra área
la unesco que es la educación o sea hay
que fortalecer mucho lo que llamamos de
la alfabetización mediática en relación
a todos estos fenómenos que estamos
viviendo
señor guillerme canela muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 ha sido
realmente un placer haber podido
dialogar con usted
muchas gracias estamos siempre a la
orden muchísimas gracias a usted a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y
recuerden que pueden volver a ver estas
entrevistas y muchísimas otras más en
france24 punto com
[Música]